good morning John this video contains a
lot of flashy lights and the theme song
from the show friends consider yourself
warned
okay we've never done this so if we suck
we still got the footage one two one two
three go
[Music]
got a
you shot
always stuck in second gear
[Music]
I'll be there for you
Andrew Huang is consistently one of my
favorite youtubers he's also in my band
Hank green and the perfect strangers he
roped me into this project to cover the
theme song from friends in nine
different genres though he didn't enjoy
mine there's probably one that you will
like thank you to Andrew for arranging
this and doing all the production's to
slims in San Francisco where we filmed
this and to the perfect strangers for
performing it with me and thanks to ez
waiter and all the people in the crowd
who sent me footage for filming this
video John you'll see me on Friday when
we will be resuming our regularly
scheduled programming the Bastille Day
always